[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
qu'il soit de l'armée de terre de la
Marine nationale ou de l'armée de l'air
depuis des décennies les tireurs des
litthes le grand public des peintres
tantôt comme des héros solitaires à
l'oral mystérieuse tantôt comme des rois
de la gâchette il véhicule bien malgré
eux des fantasmes loin de leur réalité
un bon tireur pour moi c'est quelqu'un
qui arrive à suivre une constance de tir
si quelqu'un de très patient posé et qui
met tout en oeuvre pour réussir à
toucher sa si beau premier coup ça
demande énormément de travail et de
rigueur on n'est pas dans le cinéma on
n'est pas dans la virtualité on est dans
la réalité
ce mois-ci le journal de la défense vous
invite à dépasser les clichés pour
pénétrer dans le monde préférée de ses
experts et être au coeur d'une
spécialité qui elle aussi doit s'adapter
aux nouvelles menaces vous allez
découvrir quelques-unes des missions de
ces soldats rustiques au sang-froid
maîtrisé
[Musique]
le septième art a largement participé à
la création du mythe du tireur d'élite
en le décrivant souvent comme un quasi
sur rhum pour le réalisateur Stéphane
ribojade auteur du film Forces Spéciales
la fascination pour ce personnage
romanesque s'explique pour plusieurs
raisons
je pense que le cinéma aime l'idée qu'un
personnage puisse être un guerrier à
part entière tout en étant un peu isolé
ce qui est assez jubilatoire au cinéma
parce que du coup ça permet de de
porter plus d'attention sur le
personnage sur son ressenti sur ses
émotions il y a plein de choses qui
peuvent passer parce qu'il est pas
forcément dans un acte de guerre très
sensationnel ou donc on se repose
surtout sur sa psychologie ça a une une
symbolique c'est le le guerrier froid
insensible qui visent que entre les deux
yeux et qui doit faire mouche et puis
qu'une fois qu'il a qu'il a terminé il a
aucun état d'âme non c'est pas vrai non
et puis il faut pas croire non plus que
le tireur d'élite c'est juste il est
bête et méchant et qu'on lui donne un
ordre et qui tire
non surtout au sein de ces petites
unités ils ont déjà on attend deux
d'avoir beaucoup de discernement
et de pouvoir éventuellement en ou non
engager le feu en fonction des
situations on est dans l'exagération il
faut qu'il y ait du sensationnel il faut
qu'il y ait de l'action il faut que ça
soit visuel ouais ça marche au cinéma
mais dans la réalité c'est un peu
différent
il faut y aller monsieur nous allons
rapidement nous en rendre compte sur le
plateau du Larzac dans l'Aveyron c'est
ici qu'une fois par an les tireurs
d'élite de l'armée de terre s'affrontent
lors d'un challenge national
mais en équipe comme ils ont l'habitude
de travailler en opération pendant près
d'une semaine ce sont donc 13 groupes
composés d'un chef d'équipe d'un tireur
et d'un observateur qui vont se
confronter deux jours comme de nuit à
travers 22 épreuves le panneau bleu
visuel des épreuves qui sont à la fois
tactiques techniques physiques et qui ne
sont pas uniquement centrés sur le tir
sur cet atelier chaque équipe doit
repérer cinq objets cachés dans la
végétation
ils peuvent se mettre à genoux mais
intéressante de se déplacer
selon zone d'installation donc il faut
pouvoir durer dans la durée il faut
trouver la bonne opposition idéale pour
et si on n'est pas à l'aise ça va être
compliqué de tenir au total 40 minutes
là aussi
de leur environnement d'installation tu
vois face à toi le gros carré en pierre
ok tu décales sur la gauche tu verras
une plaque d'immatriculation j'ai besoin
des chiffres
cette épreuve teste leur sens de
l'observation une qualité qui est
primordiale chez ses soldats car
paradoxalement le tir ne représente
qu'une infime partie de leur métier 10%
de leur travail en moyenne
vous mettre juste en arrière
et dans 5 minutes je vais vous donner
les coordonnées
pour le prochain point sur le terrain
leur principale mission consiste surtout
à collecter du renseignement parfois
même derrière les lignes ennemies
d'où l'obligation d'exceller dans l'art
de passer inaperçu leur discrétion et
leur patience vont d'ailleurs être
évalués dans un exercice d'approche
qui va repartir et qui va arriver
jusqu'à la position 12 euros vous avez
fait le l'épreuve 120 la profondeur avec
la bobine visuelle c'est bon ça vous
parle
les équipes ont quatre heures pour
s'infiltrer et rejoindre une zone de tir
sans être détectée par les observateurs
leur préparation doit donc
impérativement respecter quelques
principes
comme ça ils vont tous revêtir la
célèbre tenue de camouflage gilize qui
permet de se fondre dans l'environnement
[Applaudissements]
le sergent Gaétan a choisi une cape
agrémentée de bronches prélevées sur
site comme tenue plus légère et facile à
supporter sous la chaleur
cet ancien tireur d'élite à la tête de
l'équipe du 152e régiment d'infanterie
de Colmar en état son quatrième
challenge il sait donc à quelle
difficulté s'attendre en fait d'un objet
sur nous qui fait reflets et on peut
faire voir des kilomètres après il
suffit d'infos mouvement depuis une
branche au mauvais moment s'il y a pas
de vent de signaler une présence il y a
tellement de choses qui peuvent nous
déceler
c'est pour ça qu'il faut aller doucement
faut être calme
[Applaudissements]
commence alors un jeu du chat et de la
souris impitoyable physiquement et
nerveusement chacun d'eux va devoir
ramper et maintenir des positions de
gainage parfois douloureuses
au cours de cette lutte silencieuse qui
en opération peut durer jusqu'à 36
heures c'est leur ténacité et leur
abnégation qui sont éprouvés
[Musique]
on a fini on rentre à la maison
située sur un pont les observateurs qui
sont des instructeurs tireurs d'élite ne
quittent pas leur monoculaire et
anticiper différentes tactiques mises en
place si réfléchissent bien ils vont
déstabiliser les observateurs c'est à
dire nous en nous en attendant ils
peuvent se mettre un point fixe et ne
plus bouger et à ce moment-là nous aussi
on peut faire de patience et c'est à ce
moment-là que eux vont profiter pour
avancer
l'adjudant Anthony a déjà repéré deux
équipes et semble en avoir détecté une
troisième
attendez
à droite
à lancer
et vous passez dessus
reprise tu as vu où je l'ai emmené
mettez-vous tous dessus ils sont là
pour cette fois mais la traque continue
il est juste derrière ce buisson
c'est sa tête qui l'a trahi
qui t'a écrasé la cible l'intuition de
l'instructeur est bonne Gaëtan et ses
coéquipiers Anthony et Quentin sont
démasqués à leur tour sans doute un peu
trop tôt
qu'on veut parce que notre équipe donc
un peu tous entre nous il y a énormément
de découverte pour avancer c'est
vraiment horrible quoi c'est si tu
manges le sol et c'est le genre
d'endroit où normalement s'aventure pas
trop ouais voilà de nuit mais là deux
jours comme ça c'est du suicide
malgré leurs efforts aucune équipe
n'atteindra le point de rendez-vous
cette fois les évaluateurs ont gagné la
partie
le soir même tous sont attendus pour un
tiers de nuit les trinômes doivent
détecter les cibles thermiques puis les
neutraliser
c'est un travail de coordination avec un
pointeur laser
qui va ramener le tireur lui qui a une
intensificateur de lumière au niveau de
ses lunettes sur la cible et une fois
qu'elle acquisition d'objectif et il va
traiter dans la foulée
deux jours ils peuvent tirer jusqu'à
1800 mètres mais dans l'obscurité les
capacités sont plus restreintes
avec leur fusil de précision PGM et à
l'aide de fusées éclairantes ils vont
pouvoir cibler des objectifs entre 500
et 800 mètres
[Applaudissements]
la nuit a été courte le répit aussi le
lendemain matin ils sont attendus pour
un tir de bonification
toutes les munitions qui n'ont pas été
utilisées lors des ateliers vont pouvoir
être récupérés et leur apporter des
points supplémentaires
pouvoir faire un bon tire ils vont
devoir prendre les éléments suivants
entre autres pour faire simple la
distance de l'objectif qui est connue
puisque en plus on leur donne mais ils
ont aussi une moyenne pour la télérés et
tous les paramètres environnement qui
sont liés à la météorologie et bien
évidemment à la munition dans les cinq
premiers mètres depuis le bord et une
mode d'herbe en plein milieu du gravier
on confirme là-dessus d'abord
terminé début du tir
er
[Musique]
ils ont 10 minutes pour effectuer leur
tir à 400 mètres diminue de
concentration ou tout se joue à un
millimètre un souffle
à chaque coup partie une onde de choc
percute la poitrine du tireur mais se
ressent bien au-delà partout ceux qui
sont approximité derrière son fusil PGM
de plus d'un mètre 30 Anthony essaie
d'en magazine et les points sous le
regard attentif des évaluateurs pour le
jeune première classe sorti du stage
tireur d'élite longue distance il y a
seulement quelques mois la compétition
et l'occasion de se mesurer au meilleur
[Musique]
1 2 3 4
c'est un très bon résultat au vu combien
il y a des cartouches de chat vous avez
en tout cas ils ont dedans voilà
si à terre la prise en compte de
l'environnement et de la météo est
capitale la règle n'est pas forcément la
même en l'air sur la base aérienne 123
d'Orléans ici nous avons rendez-vous
avec un tireur d'élite embarqué
spécialiste de l'appui feu airsol
des biens que quand on a la porte d'un
hélicoptère on n'a pas le temps de
prendre la pression atmosphérique et la
température et le vent le relatif donc
on tire beaucoup moins loin mais
mon sot camoufle pas puisqu'on abandonne
un hélicoptère bien évidemment en
revanche on applique aussi des tactiques
que je ne détaillerai pas ici en
relation avec les pilotes
pour ce type de tir vers le sol ils
utilisent un fusil HK 417
alors bien sûr quand on l'utilise en vol
il est doté d'un récupérateur d'étui
puisque toutes les armes qui tir en vol
à bord d'une machine sont équipées d'un
récupérateur de type pour éviter
justement que les études ne passent dans
la cabine ou dans les commandes avec ce
type d'armes doté d'une lunette bien
évidemment on peut tirer jusqu'à 600
mètres pendant cette configuration en
volontiers jusqu'à 250 300 mètres
cette technique permet de délivrer des
tirs précis en limitant au maximum les
risques de dommages collatéraux et a
déjà été utilisé en opération
interception de véhicules sur axe ça
c'est produit donc lors d'une opération
en Afrique une équipe de
TVA face à intercepter un véhicule
sur hors du commandant de bord ils ont
effectué un tir de saumonce donc en
anglais warning shot
ce tir de saumonce a suffi à dissuader
les hommes à bord du véhicule donc ce
soir été se sont enfuis et ça a permis
sans causer de dégâts collatéraux sans
détruire le véhicule l'intercepter avec
eux qui de mémoire était chargée d'armes
et de produits stupéfiants
mais cela demande bien sûr une solide
expérience
d'abord il faut avoir une certaine
aisance
en vol puisque mon volet ce n'est pas
quelque chose de naturel parler à la
radio quand on est en vol c'est tous par
la radio mais pas là en la radio quand
on en vole savoir ne pas parler à la
radio quand le pilote par la radio donc
on fait partie de l'équipage on est avec
nos camarades donc on leur contrainte à
eux d'accord on allie
deux activités à risque je mets les
guillemets à risque c'est à dire le vol
qui n'est pas naturel pour un être
humain et le tir
si les tireurs des lignes de l'armée de
l'air sont capables de neutraliser des
objectifs au sol ils ont aussi la
capacité de le faire en l'air certains
d'entre eux participent à la protection
de l'espace aérien français dans le
cadre de la mission de posture permanent
de sûreté aérienne
tout comportement anormal d'un aéronef
peut donner lieu à une intervention des
moyens de l'armée de l'air et notamment
de ses hélicoptères
lorsqu'ils sont déclenchés le tireur
d'élite et son chef d'équipe mène la
plupart du temps des missions
d'assistance il se servent d'abord d'une
pancarte pour communiquer avec les
aéronef en difficulté mais ils sont
capables d'aller au-delà sur ordre en
cas de risque avéré c'est ce que nous
explique les membres de l'escadron de
protection de la base aérienne 107 de
Villacoublay on peut monter en puissance
c'est-à-dire on peut utiliser le une
arme donc avec des tirs de semences donc
c'est de la Flear des cartouches
éclairantes qui va permettre vraiment à
l'Aéronef en question de ne pas pouvoir
nier qui nous a vu c'est à dire qu'une
fois que les cartouches sont parties ça
fait un grand très lumineux il est
obligé de nous avoir vu ensuite si
l'individu est vraiment malveillant qui
refuse obtempérer on va pouvoir utiliser
la force létale
mais dans toute l'histoire de l'Armée de
l'Air aucun tireur d'élite n'a jamais eu
à ouvrir le feu le fait de voir un
hélicoptère militaire avec des tireurs
qui ouvrent la porte rien que pour
mettre un message d'avertissement c'est
suffisant pour dissuader la totalité des
aéronefs même s'ils étaient malveillants
en 2018 61 décollage d'hélicoptère sur
alerte ont eu lieu dans le cadre de la
sûreté aérienne être toujours prêt à
intervenir et donc un impératif on
s'entraîne énormément dans le but d'être
le plus professionnel possible le jour
où on devait avoir besoin de nous et
intervenir dans le cas réel faire on a
deux campagnes de tiers RR encore deux
fois par an où on s'entraîne sur des
sites qui sont tractés depuis un
hélicoptère où il y a une espèce de son
qui nous donne nos résultats en temps
réel donc on a des chargeurs à 20 et sur
une passe on part de sa palette de 500
jusqu'à 0 m en général on tire à partir
de 200 ou 300 jusqu'à le plus proche
jusqu'à son envie de notre chargeur en
se rapprochant
et une fois encore la symbiose de
l'équipage est essentielle au bon
déroulement de l'intervention on a
énormément de cohésion on se connaît on
vit ensemble au travail on se voit aussi
à l'extérieur on partage énormément de
moments on est on est vraiment proche et
on a créé des liens qui permettent de à
chaque tireur que j'ai je sais que je
vais mettre une position différente pour
le venir à la porte parce qu'il aura ses
habitudes qui sera plus performant sur
certaines sur certaines positions ou
dans certains cas de configuration
de retour sur le plateau du Larzac le
challenge des tireurs d'élite touche à
sa fin avec la très redoutée marche
commando
chaque équipe devant totaliser un
minimum de 75 kg de matériel pour
valider son épreuve
en arrivant en haut
vous franchissez à trois pour Gaëtan
Quentin et Anthony c'est la dernière
ligne droite
cette course tous vont la terminer au
mental avaler les kilomètres et les
dénivelés sans réfléchir mais en restant
soudé
avec toujours leur armement et ce fameux
fusil PGM de 17 kg ils éprouvent leur
robustesse et leur capacités physiques
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
l'équipe du 152e régiment d'infanterie
terminera la course en une heure 08
quand les meilleurs n'auront mis que 56
minutes
[Applaudissements]
les sacs sont reposés afin de vérifier
qu'aucune équipe n'est tue envie de se
délester en cours de route
du début et de la fin
[Musique]
une nouvelle fois tous sauront prouvé
leur goût de l'effort et du dépassement
de soi des qualités indispensables pour
ces hommes
une fois douchée les participants vont
pouvoir échanger avec des industriels et
tester le matériel qui pourrait les
équiper demain dans un contexte de
durcissement des conflits la
modernisation de l'équipement de ces
soldats est une des priorités du
ministère on va vous présenter deux
produits une lunette thermique et un
calculateur balistique
de l'armée de terre est présente avec un
certain nombre d'industriels qui sont
venus présenter des des matériels et
puis une équipe dans les 13 équipes qui
ont participé à ce à ce change national
et bien une équipe qui était équipée de
matériel innovants voilà donc dans une
logique un petit peu expérimentale cette
année est une année de réflexion il
s'agit aussi de
construire je dirais la capacité
tram tireur de précision tireur d'élite
du futur il y a une première échéance
qui sera en 2020 puisque le que le fusil
l'armement de dotation des tiroirs
longue distance donc le PGM 12.7 sera
rétrofité donc il sera il sera valorisé
donc c'est une échéance importante voilà
qui permettra justement de ce que je
disais tout à l'heure de conserver la
supériorité à la fois technologique et
puis doctrinal sur sur nos adversaires
cette recherche d'outils plus performant
rien n'est laissé au hasard on te pose
beaucoup de questions sur des calibres
l'amélioration de notre armement dans
fait venir des certains industriels il
nous présente leur matériel ils
présentent également le matériel aux
forces puisque c'est quand même les
forces vs et nos opérationnelles qui
vont l'utiliser souvent on dit oui mais
ça ce matériel ça fait 400 grammes de
plus rien 400 grammes des fois quand on
a pris un poids du poids 400 grammes
c'est rien du tout mais si vous rajoutez
400 g par ci et 400 grammes par là les
munitions tout ça ça fait énormément ça
fait du poids à la fin les opérationnels
c'est des sacs de 40 voire 50 kg qui
porte sur le dos donc c'est vrai que le
but c'est le poids mais après il y a
aussi la technique il faut avoir
une arme voilà qui tire à des certains
distances des distances que que l'on
demande et également dans l'optique ou
l'optronic il faut avoir du matériel de
qualité
enfin arrive-leur des résultats je
félicite toutes les équipes de la
première équipe à la dernière équipe
voilà pour avoir participé à ce
rendez-vous annuel de très haut niveau
puisque le niveau est particulièrement
relevé
les lésionnaires du deuxième ratatède à
la première marche du podium tandis que
les Diables Rouges de Colmar finissent
au milieu du tableau à la septième place
[Musique]
une année je reviendrai pour reprendre
ma revanche
les faire progresser collectivement
étaient un des objectifs du challenge
mission réussie chacun devra repartir
avec des conseils pour être le plus
performant possible
aujourd'hui une règle demeure la
différence sans doute entre un métier
fantasmé et la réalité du terrain que ce
soit sur terre dans les airs ou sur
l'eau en France ou sur les théâtres
d'opération dans l'armée conventionnelle
ou chez les forces spéciales pour ses
experts le tir est toujours le dernier
recours
[Musique]